the Joe Rogan experience tease yeah I'd
love Andre Ward for a bunch of reasons
but one for the fact that that guy
undefeated gold medalist to division
world champion guns you know what good
walked away
yes walked away and I sense that he will
stay away oh yeah he's gonna stay away
you know they talked him about Canelo
after Canelo knocked out Kovalev and he
made a dislodgement about that he's
better off for boxing even for boxing
outside of fighting you know he knows
like he's so smart man he's so smart and
so disciplined
he's just so disciplined he knows like
there's no reason there's no reason to
come back this is the right way to do it
there's there's big money and coming
back but there's also big brain damage
the ego hmm after you retire is the
biggest fight of your life you're
exactly right
these guys are defeated I'm sure if
you're a talked to off camera like be
Canelo like you know of course he must
be that just because of who he is you've
got to think that so to stop yourself
from the money the glory one more time
the possibility could you imagine coming
out of retirement and beating like - no
I've mellowed Alvarez to be able to like
you know what it's better for me and
it's better for boxing if I stay retired
and keep sitting ringside and talk about
these fights no I do that kind of
character he's a special person but also
he also has this issue with his right
shoulder you know his right shoulder was
basically broken most of his career and
he got it fixed before the second
covilhã fight and he actually wound up
hurting kovalev real bad with a right
hand which if you watch his career he
was like a left-handed fighter from the
majority of us he superspinatus was like
ripped off like it was really [ __ ] up
and he tried to rehab it with bands
instead of going through surgery when he
was young and so most of his career he
beat the best fighters in the world
called Froch all those guys one-handed
which is even more insane even more
insane and then you know had the surgery
rehab did but he said still not on a
percent
it's important there it's never gonna be
on either side right which is why people
are afraid of surgeries like you know
I'd rather do the band's everything then
take the chance it's better than it was
before I think before you have like 40%
use of his shoulder which is crazy yeah
beating the bay he said it he never felt
like he could throw a good punch he
always felt it was gonna blow out on him
she's nuts yeah [ __ ] everybody up with
one hand makes up a legend oh yeah he's
definitely a legend but I mean maybe an
underappreciated underappreciated legend
you know in terms of mainstream boxing
viewpoint I don't think the mainstream
public really appreciates how great he
was no and the way it is time or after
it will take like people reflecting on
history I think unfortunately for him
his kids and their kids might get the
benefit of who their dad or grandfather
was more so than he's getting it now
yeah well there's certain great fighters
that for whatever reason they never
really captured the public's imagination
even though they were great you know
like Marlin Starling who was a fantastic
welterweight knocked out mark Breeland
who was actually now Deontay Wilder
stranger yeah but I remember when Mark
Brillion was coming from the Olympics
and you know he was this really long
tall welterweight and he fought Starling
and Starling wasn't really wasn't
appreciated enough and Starling
you know Starling put it on them and you
realize that there's there's guys out
there that for whatever reason people
don't appreciate them as much as they
should
yeah it timings everything also you got
a catch it's unfortunate but you as much
as we hate just guys putting on an act
or like hyping themselves up with these
characters they create yeah that is
bankable I mean yes all no guys who
don't deserve the shots that they
continue to get but because they bring
an audience with their shit-talking or
with their antics and all the the show
that they put on it's better than the
fight ya know who's the most confusing
to me is Julio Cesar Chavez Jr he's
confusing to me like that last fight I'm
like what are you doing like you saying
I think I head-butted me my nose broken
quitting right I was like what are you
doing do you not understand you're
Mexican like those are the hardest
[ __ ] on earth when it comes to
boxing you're not just Mexican you are
the sharpness of the man like he won
something like 31 world title fights
some insane number
he's has the record of world title wins
which is also like an unattainable goal
if you decide to go into boxing and your
father is Julio Cesar Chavez dude one of
the goats what do you hope far can you
hope to get in legacy like I almost feel
bad for the guy like because there's got
to be so much going on in his head right
to put him towards that but yet he's
talented he's [ __ ] he's a good
fighter he like his skills his ability
to put hands on people are very good but
I think also there's something about
growing up wealthy it's just almost
impossible like you kind of have to have
some part of your life that was [ __ ]
up and you didn't think it was gonna
work out where well you didn't think it
was there was a future and there's a
burn that never goes out there's like a
little fire that never goes out ease is
a greater challenge than adversity yes
it is man there's something about
comfort that just makes [ __ ] out of
people it just does it's so hard to
overcome that you can't you can't even
forcibly remove yourself from that
comfort it's very few human beings are
able to really achieve greatness when
they grow up with with great wealth and
privilege is something about that that
life of leisure and and and knowing that
everything's gonna be okay you know like
your dad made fifty million dollars
you're gonna be fine you know there's
something about that that's just for
whatever reason it just haunts the
haunts people yeah I mean he would
almost have to have there be something
burning brightly inside him almost like
a resentment for his father
unfortunately
love could propel you right like even
come anywhere near his legacy but you
definitely have to hate the guy just to
be like fire burning bright enough to
attain anything close to what he did and
I feel bad for his dad - you know dad
watching him quit but you know you gotta
use a loving father man it's not the
first time he's been embarrassed he
keeps coming back like alright this is
the one this is the time one more
the Canelo fight was a rough one - no
I'll classed him you know
Cannell was just just a better fighter
it's show biz not a quitter like at
least like this last time yeah he may
have had a point like maybe was like
head but maybe the elbows but quitting
and boxing obviously is the cardinal
same lesson that [ __ ] up it wasn't his
nose was pouring blood and he couldn't
breathe out of it anymore and it was
from a blatant foul like he looked okay
right yeah maybe there's something going
on that we couldn't see but he looked
okay and then he was you know took
videos from the hospital the next day
with tape on his nose and like lay low
for a while bro
[Applause]